vous savez que choisir comment choisir
l'animateur préféré des français quand
on est à la tête de touche pas à mon
poste même l'été la réponse est simple
c'est ma petite idée prend les
animateurs des émissions de ces 8es en a
qu'un pas
dans la catégorie awards de l'animateur
préféré des français les nommés sont
cyril hanouna d'en face à baba merci
jean luc d'être là merci saint-benoît
baba j'ai pas compris ben c'est comme ça
qu'on m'appelle ma mère à ça lui faisait
plaisir cyril hanouna dans tpm p
l'exo 7 g anglais mokhtar y était on a
vu des anglais des anglais what is also
n'est pas moi cyril hanouna dans le 6 et
[Applaudissements]
et cyril hanouna daudet pembe week-end
allait discuter de sa carte
vous avez jusqu'à 40
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paris
alors vous donner c'est qu'est le merdy
matters j'hésite à tout le monde je suis
partagé aussi je vais faire ça aux
costumes ouais mais je pense que c'est
celui qui l'a alors oui c'est d'en face
à badens
costume gris non non costume noir que
suggère le basket ouais je dirais face à
bah bah ça va plus à le devenir de riz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une corner
moi aussi j'ai dit évidemment énormément
mais j'aime énormément le cirill du 6 à
7 qui animateurs des bar mitzvah alors
voilà autant de la paire je la regarde
il avait complètement là c'est la
rentrée regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
jeremy
[Applaudissements]
on agir de la même avocat robert
[Musique]
céline quand il faut que tu prends le 6
à 7 et ne sait absolument pas ce qui
pendant 40 minutes des fois même plus
ils improvisent tout du début à la fin
parce que rien n'est prévu bien
évidemment fait c'est absolument rien de
ressasser dedans donc le 7 d'or est
attribuée à
quoi le 7 d'or le 6 et le 7 juin sept
d'or les prêts à l'époque
tu lavandula garder alors je les données
pour une asso sur les motos
rivieras sénat ça s'appelle
[Rires]
le subito on devrait arrêter sa carrière
et dieu seul sait qu'ils sont nombreux
avec 100 membres les nominés sont
dans la catégorie awards de l'animateur
qui devrait arrêter la télé les deux
maisons thierry ardisson son mauvais jeu
d'acteur vous savez comme moi non mais
c'est vrai oui c'est là où j'avais
rencontré la rue d'orchamps michel cymes
mais seul médecin qui vous donne la
migraine venu effectivement en vitamines
sels assure les missions qui vous fait
passer direct et avec le sourire en
dernière année de médecine t pour
bérénice ravi d'être à vos côtés comme
ça veut dire flou mais
bruno guillon un animateur à la hauteur
des cadeaux offerts dans son émission
votre cadeau ce
l'indispensable boîtes de petits pois
toujours utile dans un placard quand il
n'y a pas d'eau rien en plus l'eau et
jarry dans le big show et on comprend
mieux pourquoi il n'est pas resté
humoriste qu'on fasse entrer le livreur
aux abords
enfin trône
[Musique]
on sait peu choisit
alors jean louis gillet je crois je vous
promets jarry j'aime pas
c'est une caricature de lui-même puis
j'aime pas c'est comme eric antoine
j'aime pas les gens qui rient de même
oui si les blacks qui rigole leurs
propres blagues je sais pas si j'ai un
minimum de respect j'ai pas un peu drôle
sans rire de soi non mais j'ai pas et je
comme lui c'est abat sa voix ou et un
truc bizarre à la voix
et
j'arrive moi je dis ça parce que voilà
ça y est il a fait son temps il faut
laisser la place aux jeunes et moi
thierry ardisson lui j'ai pas il en
manque un mais pourquoi pas on pouvait
pas faire plaisir un peu mon non plus
chez pas michel cymes vous savez que
comme vous je ne porte pas spécialement
dans cas je le trouve mauvais en télé je
pense qu'il devrait retourner aux
urgences ou dans un hyper v ner il est
encore passé le chanteur lui il aimait
les émissions vitamine c qui vous donne
envie de dormir vous voyez ce que je
veux dire un port paradoxe donc ouais je
pense que michel cymes pas bon et
ardisson l'hôtel du temps naufrage
magali vergnes choix je dirais ardisson
parce que c'était une star et c'est un
grand animateur et là il commence à
faire de la merde et on va avoir un on
va avoir un médium on va avoir une
mauvaise un mauvais souvenir de lui en
fait je suis révoltée qui a rétabli les
autres on sait déjà que c'est un
naufrage bon à part ça mais moi j'adore
jarry au nouvion s'est allongée bruno
guillon les autres c'est bon animateur
on a eu on a eu on a regardé ce que
faisait cyril et on a une palette un peu
de tout ce qu'ils savaient faire c'est à
dire le one man show moi qui étais le
côté 6 à 7 l'interview politique et le
le côté jeu s'est animé une émission
très bien de la reine avenant mais pas
du tout alors moi je dis ce que je pense
et je me sens bien je
vois les retraites on est là dans l'es4
on se mettrait j'arrive de côté se
trouve assez drôle maison les trois
autres ne sont pas capables de faire
c'est exact mais celle ci m il est
triste il est moi sur leurs gardes j'ai
envie de pleurer je suis partie de la
vie
on attend non pas d'accord mais il est
comme ça quand je parle du cancer peut
pas non plus
[Musique]
non mais non mais enfin il essaye de le
rendre un petit peu sympathique bruno
guillon c'est terrible une aiguille on
ça devrait être aussi c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait du one man c'est quelqu'un
qui est censé être drôle c'est un benêt
d'observer la limmat maire de riom
après ça on peut on peut ne pas aimer le
lan et personnages
on a une mission c'est pareil
il t'aime beaucoup de cordes à son arc
voilà jamais notable est le problème
d'ardisson c'est beaucoup trop d'ego et
maintenant pas les projets qui suivent
il a dégueulé go surdimensionné et
bertrand ont besoin tout le monde admet
une toute petite erreur
concernant justement thierry l'artisan
je viens je lai attaché à de nombreuses
reprises il s'est en croit la liste est
vraiment pour le mouvement royaliste et
lui qui prône le retour de la monarchie
en france il est vraiment content le
système présidentiel non c'est pas pour
ça que je veux est forcément promis je
tenais juste à apporter ce tout petit
clerc une petite info c'est pour ça
qu'il a été décapitée bien si beaucoup